I decided to write the book right now as
a kind of handbook for the 08 election I
wanted to look at what the right head
down to this country over the last
almost eight years and why why did we
allow the right to hijack our democracy
and dominate the debate because I feel
when we understand why we are going to
find it much easier to clean the mess
not let it happen again and above all
make sure that John McCain is not the
winner in November oh wait so that's why
I've included an entire chapter on John
McCain where I described how he has been
hijacked by the right well that's why
things with the key and point I wanted
to make in the book in terms of the
culpability of the media how they became
in neighbors and so my first two
chapters are about the media the first
chapter is called equal time for lies
because I think one of the problems has
been the way the media and like to
present every issue as though it has two
sides even when the truth is solidly on
one side or the other and as a result
it's been very confusing for the
American public because and the right
doesn't win doesn't need to win the
argument it just needs to make people
doubt what the truth is and we've seen
that again and again we've seen it on
global warming who say I'll go on the
one hand talking about the dangers of
global warming and Senator James Inhofe
on the other hand talking about how
global warming is a fraud we've seen
that again and again on Iraq when the
truth is absolutely clear that Iraq has
been a catastrophe of origin for the
United States but in fact the media and
many of our leaders continue to
presenters and we're winning there is a
mixed bag